[Musique]
je présentais nos amis il ya besoin je
fais tout bon bah la tâche à elie semoun
qui sans cela se passe très bien entre
vous je crois mais oui je conçois ça
fait un cours de français un très beau
couple
c'est très beau couple n'ont eu qu'à est
que vous connaissez nos kits et jean
pierre coffe ombassa c'est à ça c'est
vous avez des enfants on avait 15 ans
quand vous l'avez connu jean pierre
j'avais 13 ans et demi ouais vous avez
en ce moment et c'est pour ça qu'on vous
a invité parce que l'émission s'appelle
tout le monde en parle et tout le monde
parle de vous à cause de la pièce que
vous jouez qui s'appelle maria callas
master class la leçon de chant tous les
soirs en tous les soirs standing-ovation
à laurent voulzy est allé aussi oui
exceptionnel voilà voilà
alors nous pouvons nous ajouter
c'est incroyable j'ai vu de la pièce
mise en scène par polanski a en faisant
troisième fois obligé de parler tout à
l'heure mais avec fanny ardant et et
c'était pas mal oui mais bon voilà
c'était pas mal mais là c'était
exceptionnel si un seul spectacle à les
voir à paris en ce moment c'est celui
c'est tout ban a bien fait de venir
atépa sur sa toile à paris donc pas et
vous avez déclaré je reviens à la vie
dans laquelle as tu serais beaucoup
moins bien tu swiss a déclaré marie je
reviens à la vie donc c'est vous dit
vous avez déclaré aussi depuis quelques
années on m'avait mise à la retraite
persuadé que j'étais l'aide bête
méchante et sans talent alors quand on
vous voit effectivement on comprends pas
comment des gens auraient pu penser ça
au delà de généralement ceux là je les
épouses oui bon ça fait pas beaucoup ça
au fait que quatre on y viendra
au delà de l'ajustement de cet
autodénigrement qui est habituel chez
vous est ce que vous avez vraiment
flipper un moment est ce que vous vous
êtes dit bah voilà pas c'est fini on n a
plus jamais me chercher ouais oui je me
suis retrouvé seul au monde
l'aide bête méchante et il faut chez
ouais ça fait beaucoup
et comme hancock est venu vous chercher
alors s'intéressant à savoir moi je suis
allé voir moi d'abord il dit le coût de
chéri bon d'accord ça n'est pas le pérou
mais on peut peut-être faire quelque
chose ouais les entreprises ont un
enfant c'est ça c'est bien et puis voilà
et puis non non je crois qu'ils se sont
trompés 1 quand ils m'ont proposé master
class c'est françoise hardy était pas
libre
sheila a été en train de présenter une
émission tv ouais ouais donc donc ils
sont dix ravalant rookie toujours la
dent dure sur les yéyés parce qu'à
l'époque j'ai retrouvé des papiers de
l'époque non quand on vous parlait des
yéyés vous disiez on vous demander ce
que vous pensiez de sylvie vartan et
françoise hardy et vous disiez mais
faut-il vraiment penser quelque chose
donc je vois c'est une espèce de
continuité comme ça c'est bien voulu
donner de la suite dans les idées c'est
bien reconverti payet vous m'arrivera
pas les gens pas dit où m'attendre en
venant parler d'abord en parler de la
callas non mais
quand même pas parler de cette pièce de
tout n'est pas dit justement c'est une
pièce donc de terrence mcnally qui sont
là génie alors moi je peux le dire parce
que je le pratique tous les soirs et en
principe quand on pratique un auteur au
bout de un mois deux mois on commence à
voir les failles on commence à voir les
endroits où c'est un petit peu moins
bien travaillé ou c'est ce type est un
génie
d'abord il a pris des notes sur la
callas parce qu'il a assisté au mécénat
6 tc licour faut le dire une sommité
voilà sur les courts de gestion des
cours de chant que kallas a donné
pendant deux ans à la julliard school à
new york et il était dans la salle en
auditeur libre et il prenait des petites
notes sur rien sur un geste sûr sur une
inflexion de voix sur une phrase sur qui
avait l'air de rien il a laissé reposer
comme du bon vin pendant 20 ans et au
bout devant vous êtes comme du bon vin
bourgogne en même temps c'est un peu
normal et c'est finalement au bout de 20
ans et nous avions parlé de cocaïne vous
aurez regarde je sais même pas ce que
c'est je peux regarder que le ciel
d'accord comme ça devient un peu chaud
je vais demander à notre ami serge
qu'elles font rêver c'est un petit peu
la lumière là mais on est dans une
ambiance on a un peu plus cosy alors
dont on vers une hyper view l'hyper view
c'est pas compliqué on à barrie on est
on est ça me confirme à la pallice et
une interview vérité donc vous allez
dire la vérité mais vous je sais qu'en
général je ne savais pas dire le sait
pas dit autre chose que la vérité on a
menacé en commun c'est qu'on attendait
oui au mentor je suis toujours là volt
sera coûté assez cher et ça m'a coûté
assez cher dans notre carrière
trois fois de la télé - c'est vrai moi
j'étais internet de micro pendant dix
ans voilà house house house à la télé
atd pas un bon répond au besoin le pas
la peau donc on arrive à fond mais
toujours dans votre célèbre
autodénigrement vous avez déclaré je
pense en parlant de vous et de la classe
que nous sommes des femmes laides avis
c'est pourquoi on dit souvent on verra
pourquoi vous le dit d'ailleurs on y
viendra mais je dire c'est quand même
eric singer oui elle
elle a été moins elles étaient moches
plein de boutons en grosse amende
ah oui 1943 45
elle est franchement avant franchement
un tirable alors messieurs c'est une
info si tu n étais pas cet adjectif un
tir à un tir à ben oui c'est fin de
série mais c'est une autre celle là non
c'est une voie là
notre ami car la garenne leur chien bo
soir car la 4l
vous connaissez jean pierre coffe qui ne
connaît pas non non non c'est bien comme
laurent ruquier lycées bolt et achats
vous connaissez d'achat oui tout le
monde connaît tâche à tout le monde que
l'état nation qu'on a mieux marie
laforêt surtout à mosnac bon alors il
peut les enlever si ça pose un problème
mais je vais vous mettre un petit peu
c'est pourquoi je dis ça pour votre
lumière pour vous soyez plus beau mais
c'est bien mais ça je n'ai pas cette
impression là comme ça alors qu'arles
regardez bien c'est une hyper view donc
et donc vous allez voir c'est après ça
vous arrive est injuste après ça va être
votre hyper dieu non marie laforêt la
griffe au fond de vous demander
d'enlever ses lunettes elle a des yeux
selon lui il faut pas d'accueil de m car
est votre monture avait vraiment
vraiment à leur écoute être sur ses yeux
dans mes frais qui n'était pas un rêve
attendu que c'est qu'il a dit au
téléphone hier soir il est très amoureux
de vous laissez pas vous dire naze effet
voilà ils n'osaient pas dix ans le
régime fait rouge fait plaisir tu veux
plusieurs tonneaux et donc lycées marie
laforêt est le candidat des yeux
magnifiques c'est une bonne comédienne
est une excellente interprète chanteuse
je suis fou d'elle voilà je suis en
train de me demander ce que j'aimerais
être dans tasha enfin bon qu'est-ce
qu'il est mort hier de vente achat nand
entajan tâche à toi tu voulais être les
montures le monture moyens ou sûr c'est
pas mal tu peux changer de branche oui
bon on continue donc
moi j'aimerais que nous rencontrent
racontiez cette histoire formidable
votre début de carrière c'est un
véritable conte de fées c'est en à
cannes en 1959 au casino municipal vous
arriver habillés comme tout le monde pas
maquillée bah oui non mais c'est
extraordinaire cette histoire pourquoi
vous arrive et ce comme nous mais pas du
tout je voulais dire mais c'est vrai non
mais attendez c'est une émission que
j'appelais naissance d'une étoile
organisé par aurait pas vous jouer une
scène de six personnages en quête
d'auteur
c'est là que vous rencontrez louis malle
qui vous qui vous j'ai d'abord rencontré
raymond rouleau oui alors parce que ça
c'est vraiment là vous dire que d'autres
à nos jeunes amis téléspectateurs c'est
vraiment oui on peut pas raconter
raymonde en si peu de temps c'est nous
génie c'est le génie des eaux le génie
connaissez-vous le metteur en scène
indépendante et ça tu vois le rosé c'est
le grand metteur en scène est ignorée au
théâtre avec ce monstre ou l'eau c'est
exceptionnel
bah ouais mais je ne sais rien chaque
les vieux sont là pour écouter les yeux
du vieux sauveterre il s'est donc c'est
donc c'est un louis malle qui vous a
balisé marie laforêt parce que oui mais
comme vous pourquoi marie laforêt comme
ça celle ci s'est pas marie moi j'avais
dit marina mari d'une loi c'est déjà
pris non non c'était pas encore pris à
l'est pas ils ont fait du maine du
chemin la barrière
bon depuis huit heures du soir tome on
était bourré on a dit la forêt au s'est
arrêté là elle m'a dit va très bien sapé
la normale et on va on va pas faire tout
votre carrière parce que vous avez fait
des tas de choses vont enfin être aux
longs cils dirhams ainsi dire un mot de
plein soleil quand même avec de longs et
maurice ronet vous avez été préféré à
audrey hepburn pour ce film par rené
clément vous le savez ça non je crois
par à 6 ici assez dans toutes les
histoires du cinéma c'est vrai mais bien
entendu
oui j'écris bien porté son nom je vous
dit ça par vous dit ça par modestie non
importe ce que j'ai jamais pas
l'information et où ça devait être
audrey hepburn et jacques charrier
oui jacques charrier qui avec brigitte
bardot dans un métal et vous l'êtes pas
sortir de l'hôtel et on peut le
comprendre et donc finalement ça a été
alors après bon il ya eu la fille aux
yeux d'or qui vous a donné votre surnom
albicocco que j'ai épousé tant qu'à
faire
j'avais comme je suis moi bah voilà donc
les amours ses lapins qu'était un film
as vous croisez vos pieds
ruquier on est en affaires vous croisez
vous appelez on se marie on se marie
munch est d'accord dès demain matin
on ne sait jamais j'ai fait certainement
pinon bien 4 404 voilà je serai le
sixième bon pourquoi pas bah oui non n'y
a pas de problème moi je suis d'accord
je te laisse oui pierre palmade et le
bmx bel exemple d'un mariage d'un
mariage réussi
c'était joli 6 mois bon alors on passe
sur tous vos films sociaux voyous
joyeuses pâques mari le chanteur n'est
pas une 4 avant finalement j'hésite
vous n'êtes jamais approprié pour vous
n'êtes jamais approprié la place que
vous méritiez au cinéma c'est finalement
vous auriez dû être gazés
non je suis pas carriériste du tout moi
gp j'ai passé mon temps à regarder les
gens à absorber à regarder une attitude
un geste un grade mains une paire de
lunettes
j'ai appris mon métier comme ça et j'ai
pas provoquer un rôle
vous n'êtes pas été élevé comme ça parce
que karl lagerfeld quand on lui dit vous
fait plein de choses je travaillais pour
des tas de marque etc
car vous répondez vous dites vous mais
c'est de l'arrivisme singer j'ai pas été
éduqués pour être une victime ça c'est
sûr mais oui pas parce que on est arrivé
ce qu'il faut être scellé contraire du
début de la victime
warren victimes mais je ne me prends pas
non plus pour le com de la réglisse ou
non de comparer leurs maisons il a été
agréé au premier passage
vous savez je n'ai pas été éduqué pour
alice que moi les plus vulnérables au
malawi tout mon problème c'est que
j'étais une victime en 68 au moment où
vous allez chanter vous dites je vais
chanter sur scène
quel cauchemar dans un an je serai à
pontault d'amalur pontault dame faut le
dire c'est l'asile des vieux artistes
quant aux dames
les maisons de retraite maison de
retraite pardon et coffe qui s'est déjà
renseigné sais pas ce qu'ils disent que
jean-pierre ce soir ils ont eu sortir de
ventes alimentent aux dames c'est quand
même plus chier que ris orangis oui
c'est vrai mais alors b on y sera en
israël
d'ailleurs on peut donc non c'est
incroyable dit c'est fini raconte dans
un an je suis à potsdam après ça vous
vendez quand même 35 millions de disques
donc c'était c'est bizarre quand même
c'est de cette façon des stades et j'y
ai réfléchi extrêmement tara c'est parce
que je suis assez lent départ
remarquablement intelligente et il m'a
fallu beaucoup d'aléas savage oui non
mais il m'a fallu beaucoup d'années pour
comprendre qu' on ne vend pas par hasard
35 millions de disques il y a quelque
chose qui fait que le paraître n'est pas
ce qui fait vendre
par contre lettres auxquelles je n'étais
jamais intéressé que je dénigre est en
permanence et d'ailleurs que j'avais pas
visité celui là faisait qu' il touchait
les gens on vend pas 35 millions de 10
par hasard comme vous le dites si bien
oui donc ça me sert chanson de marie
laforêt vous non mais je veux pas qu il
les chante we jamais ces noms ne
chantait pas alors je vous ai entendu ça
ça si c'est justement ce qui m'arrive a
pourtant bien revoir ta mère
non non c'est parce que ça mais c'est
pas grave c'est parfait grâce à du mans
fils comment tu chantais avant et
comment tu chantes maintenant parce que
je suis d'obédience judaïque
oui oui parce que moi j'en ai trois
enfants d'accord j'ai vu chez moi j'ai
eu peur et j'ai deborah alors grâce à
dieu mon fils c'est pas moi qui vais ça
sert la table ça c'était il ya quinze
jours
donc oui alors toujours dans les tous
vous connaissez quoi elle marie laforêt
tirèrent 10 ans parce que c'est pas tout
de poser des questions mais vous avez
incapable de chanter une chanson va
chanter une chanson de marie laforêt
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est la seule chance aux jo zappé
sur l'album pas avec gilbert vous en
supplie pas guy béart
non non c'est insupportable c'est beau
c'est beau mais quand même quand il dit
des mariés quand on sera mariée on
choisira ensemble d'accords baril
d'accord vous l'aimez bien guibert
j'aime beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup ton dix ans maintenant
non non je les aime beaucoup c'est
vraiment un des rares type extrêmement
intelligent et bien cultiver de ce
métier très intelligent de la finesse de
l'originalité dans ce mondial lui-même
oui oui tout à fait bien sûr que je le
connais bien c'est c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de qualités il
ya longtemps vous l'avez vu j'ai discuté
avec charles aznavour qui m'a dit la
même chose
ouais ok peut-être non non je t'assure
que c'est vrai c'est sûr tout à fait
attention c'est surtout un grand auteur
de toute façon oui ah oui bien sûr bon
alors tout jeune homme beaucoup réveil
coffre à gants moto le libérer vous
connaissez guy béart qu'on ait cette
chance en fait qu'on n'est pas
personnellement ce n'est vous habitez
pas guy béart qua non du gard il salit
pas de tags étaient soumises à
l'étranger mois en 1969 dans paris ce
jour toujours et au dénigrement vous
dites je m'auto punis je voudrais mourir
lentement après avoir beaucoup souffert
ces terribles sur des trucs à vous donc
l'avait dit non mais je ne savais pas
encore à ce moment là que j'avais été
violée ouais c'est ça je l' ai appris
très tard comme ça juste que tu oui mais
voilà sur c'était la sélection mois ces
déclarations sont directement issues
d'un traumatisme qui était occulté qui
fait que pendant des années j'ai vécu
des choses que je ne comprenais pas bien
je me touche je m'auto punissait je je
je voulais jamais être au mieux je
voulais toujours disparaître ont beau et
dire une chose comme ça c'est réellement
révélateur non c'est pas terrible que ça
a pris je voudrais mourir lentement
après avoir beaucoup souffert comme ça
ça veut ça voulait dire j'aime la vie
oui mais c'était s'est il fait il
fallait voir ça en dépit de tout l'amour
de la vie était plus fort que tout don
pour m'en séparer je n'imaginais
quinquin supplice extrêmement longues
qui fasse que finalement j'ai envie de
mourir
oui et alors quand vous avez révélé ce
que tu fasses un traumatisme disons dans
dans paris match c'était l'année
dernière je pense vous avez vous
attendiez à être soulagé en fait vite
j'ai pas été soulagés en fait on m'a
regardé comme une pestiférée ou comme
une malade oui et le discours des gens a
beaucoup changé visible moi je
connaissais l'événement depuis déjà 10
ans le fait de le mettre dans le public
je me suis dit qu'un sabre libéré c'est
une libération maintenant allez on en
voit on en voit au loin c'est la batte
de baseball je vais j'y vais j'y pense
plus c'est terminé ouais pas du tout à
partir de là les gens commençaient à me
parler ça va alors là je me suis dit
j'ai vu vraiment quelque chose de grave
alors que moi j'étais déjà en train d'en
sortir mais on a remise dedans mais là
laurent ça va très bien je vois ça je
vois ça normal à ce que vous dites aussi
passé par enfin sur vous l'avez déclaré
donc donc c'est public hein c'est pas
vous que vous dites que vous suivrez
longtemps cherché à retrouver
inconsciemment bien sûr avec avec les
hommes cet instant où quand ça vous est
arrivé vous avez capitulé c'est à dire
vous cherchiez que les hommes
inconsciemment cette espèce d'abandon
comme ça non c'était pas un abandon
c'était un premier contact
ça a été la première fois qu'on m'a
adressé la parole si j'ose dire
c'était la première phase a été ce
premier contact que j'ai pensé au départ
être un contact amical qui s'est
transformée d'une manière terrible mais
le premier contact était un contact
chaleureux
c'est la première fois qu'on venait me
voir et non pas ma soeur qui avait dix
ans de plus que moi ou ma mère ou
quelqu'un d'autre
c'était moi donc j'ai essayé de
retrouver ça et à chaque fois mais c'est
d'une tristesse en france se sont
rendues à la famille
abl non mais c'est vous dire que c'est
un schéma initial tout bêtement ne
faisait pas été victime de ce qu'on
appelle le syndrome de stockholm
amoureux exactement amoureux de
exactement c'est ça c'est ça qui lui en
fait quand quand j'en sors tes à dans la
foule qui était vraiment capable de
faire beaucoup souffrir
ouais vous alliez vous étiez attiré
inconsciemment par le par les gens qui
vous qui avec avait un air sympa de
l'extérieur synthétique voyais les gens
à l'air sympa l'extérieur et qui en fait
sans les ordures voilà non c'est pour ça
qu'elle est dure à l'extérieur et je
suis très sympa très joueurs
merci pour moi ça fait toujours plaisir
de présenter une émission à la
télévision un peu d'ordre
continuez vous êtes bien là mais on est
bien tous les deux équipes au et mario
c'est d'aller au fond de la toile pour
la télévision absolument bon voisin
pierre
ça vous rappelle des souvenirs tous les
jours il faut pas un peu plus fort oui
une dernière chose il ya une rumeur
terrible qui a couru sur vous un simple
choix ça peut pas être pire que tout ce
que j'ai entendu mon nom on a monté chez
madame quoi c'est celle là c'est celle
là oui oui vous imaginez moi chez marc
hé ben oui c'est ça oui mais pourquoi je
pense en tout cas ça a été répétée vous
sauriez vous l'auriez vu
et c'est sincèrement onac comme je suis
j'aurais été chez madame vous sauriez
marié le premier jour dans c'est pas
tout ça mais je le dirai oui oui c'est
vrai oui je le dirai et j'accueille
maintenant madame de l'avant des rats
[Musique]
soir je ne vous appellerai pas marie
laforêt car si vous n'êtes pas en
promotion pour quoi que ce soit vous
êtes ici pour vous exprimer merci
d'avoir choisi d'ailleurs tout le monde
en parle
je voulais dire à ce sujet thierry tout
à l'heure vous avez dit si c'était pas
moi ce serait un autre ce serait pareil
je vous dis tout de suite il savait pas
été vous je ne serais pas là merci
saison
je vous demande de vous inviter bien
alors il ya quinze jours sur ce plateau
antoine schuller le fils de didier
schuller en compagnie du journaliste
jean paul guillaume est venu témoigner
et d'ailleurs depuis sa servi à quelque
chose parce que depuis didier schuller
est rentré en france et il a été
incarcéré suite à la dénonciation de son
fils de l'actualité d'un vrai [ __ ] la
vraie alors effectivement alors la
presse a dit en parlant de la
dénonciation d'antoine qu'ils étaient
manipulés manipulé par jeu spa par les
socialistes pour faire du tort à chirac
on a dit aussi qu'il était manipulé par
vous alors si c'est jospin qu'il
manipule on comprend effectivement et si
c'est vous on va essayer de comprendre
pourquoi vous l'auriez manipuler antoine
schouller malheureusement d'ailleurs et
personne ne peut le manipuler
vous avez expliqué interview vérité
[Musique]
on
alors la reprendre les choses au début
pour tout le monde comprenne bien
vous avez été mariée avec un ami de
didier schuller qui s'appelle eric de
l'avant des rats qui est un français
agent de change qui vit en suisse
lui il avait été mariée en premières
noces avec catherine hennessy
qu'héritière adecco n'y a qu'ainsi ils
ont eu un enfant des pantins s'appelle
diego de l'avant des rats qui est ami
avec antoine schuller fac était ami avec
antoine schuller comme les deux papas
étaient amis alors on va d'abord
commencer par ça parce qu'on a beaucoup
parlé dans la presse et j'aimerais que
vous expliquer là dessus votre mariage
avec eric de l'avant des races s'est pas
bien passé très bien passé il s'est
extrêmement bien passé j'ai eu la chance
de tomber sur un homme courtois
intelligent cultivé gentil et pendant je
dois dire pendant 13 ans j'ai vécu un
mariage extrêmement heureux jusqu'aux
derniers mois de notre notre mariage qui
a été très traumatisants extrêmement
bouleversant et où je n'ai strictement
rien compris et ce qui se passait voilà
vous pouvez continuer non je continue
parce que c'est vrai que c'était pas
très bien passé avec catherine si ça
c'était satiété comme pour moi ça s'est
extrêmement bien passé pour elle a eu
deux enfants donc avec monsieur de
l'avant des rats elle a été je crois
extrêmement heureuse pendant pendant
sept ans et brusquement les choses ont
dérapé pour elle elle a eu un accident
sur lequel elle avait des gros doutes
c'est un accident de moto pour elle ce
sera un accident de voiture pour moi à
partir de ce moment là ses amis
commencent à changer à son égard
son mari l'a dit alcoolique drogué
dépressive dans une secte et dieu sait
quoi
et il va tenter de la mettre par la
fenêtre
ce qui fait que catherine m6 partira
avec son sac à main laissant ses deux
enfants derrière elle
je suis persuadé moi même puisque je
n'ai aucune raison de douter de ce que
nous dit mon mari que effectivement
catherine m6 est une fois le furieux
donc je vais élever diego et isabelle
comme mes propres enfants et je les
élève donc en même temps que mes propres
enfants dans une ambiance extrêmement
joyeuse et agréable votre mari a eu un
comportement effectivement un petit peu
bizarre avec vous il dormait avec un
couteau à cran d'arrêt soit table de
nuit c'est vrai que dans mes pas il me
montrait le côtoie de près
c'est vrai qu'il vous prenait le pouls
pendant la nuit pour savoir si c'est une
version extrêmement expurgée des faits
tels qu'ils se seraient passées comme
s'en souviendra peut-être nathalie
charron puisque je faisais une une
couverture pour votre beauté j'ai reçu
malheureusement important de décor sur
la figure qui fait à peu près 70 kg en
acier et je les prie juste ici donc
hôpital scanner on termine tant bien que
mal interview les photos que l'on peu de
travers avec un chapeau sur la tête je
suis peut-être comme ça et nous rentrons
à genève et là à ce moment là je
commence à me sentir mal vertiges
nausées
je vais à nouveau faire un scanner et on
demande à mon mari de ne pas me quitter
parce que je dors 20 heures par jour de
ne pas le quitter parce que je risque de
tomber dans le coma il va se passer
quelque chose de très extraordinaire de
7 heures du matin à 1h du matin mon mari
me laissera seule sans manger sans boire
il fait très chaud nous sommes au mois
d'août et pendant deux jours d'affilée
ça se reproduit et le deuxième soir je
suis interrogative et je mime quelqu'un
qui ne bougent plus voir ce qu'il va se
passer
et mon mari arrivent à côté du lit et
simplement il pousse ma main c'est ce
que veut dire cette simple phrase vous
en déduisez ce que vous voulez les
freins de la voiture qui lâche brûle
très étonnant quand on a une voiture qui
est une rente jeu revers quand on est
envoyé en mission à monter à au festival
de cannes et qu'on a pour mission
apparemment de rencontrer monsieur muhyo
et de revenir avec une certaine somme
d'argent dont je parlerai uniquement
devant les juges
mais je suis heureuse de pouvoir le dire
à l'avance devant vous ce soir comme je
le ferai à chaque fois que j'irai voir
un juge
je les fais et j'ai essayé de le faire
très souvent pendant huit ans
aujourd'hui j'ai pris la décision de
parler d'abord à la presse avant de me
présenter devant un juge de façon à ce
que l'opinion publique française soit au
courant de ce qui se passe mais c'est
une prothèse d'une certaine façon me
protéger je vais vous dire très
sincèrement je pense que j'aurai une
peau de banane qui glissera sous un
camion lequel sera écrasée par un avion
que j'aurai une balle dans la tête que
je serais suicidé
je serai très déprimé mais quoi qu'il en
soit aujourd'hui j'ai enfin la
possibilité après huit ans de dire ce à
quoi nous avons tous à faire face tous
ici nous les français nous avons à faire
face à une organisation
extraordinairement dangereuse et le
gouvernement ne peut rien y faire
alors vous découvrez un jour que votre
mari a primé en assurance vie quand il
est le bénéficiaire si vous décédez vous
découvrez aussi d'autres choses
n'étaient pas tout étaler ici m'enfin je
vous en prie faites le bac il a des
relations homosexuelles avec un homme
politique internationale très connu vous
finissez par découvrir que les affaires
de votre mari s'en sont pas très claires
en fait c'est à dire que je ne découvre
rien du tout je j'ai tellement la
trouille que je fini par demander à des
gardes du corps de venir et en une heure
je dis à mon mari je suis désolé je
resterai pas dans le même pièce que toi
sois tu vas à l'hôtel soit moi je vais à
l'hôtel mais c'est terminé j'ai eu trop
la trouille
donc nous séparons très abruptement il
me laisse dans l'appartement qu'il a mis
à mon nom pour une raison que j'ignore
mais que les juges j'espère comprendront
mieux que moi et je découvre là ce qui
était supposé être les archives de la
charge eric de l'avant des rats ce ne
sont pas des archives
ce sont des papiers et en une un
ordinateur dans l'appartement
notre ordinateur dans un appartement qui
est en mon nom un autre ordinateur
contient effectivement 95 % de dossiers
qui lui appartiennent auquel je ne
comprends rien pendant quatre mois
et au bout de quatre mois je commence à
découvrir la vérité et c'est tout à fait
tout à fait est extraordinaire
et abominable on a dix qui refusait de
lui verser une pension alimentaire et
tout ce que vous disiez c'était
justement pour le forcer à vous la
verser effectivement j'ai demandé
pendant cinq ans il ya une demande
d'annulation de mariage qui a été
instruite cette demande d'annulation de
mariage dans la mesure où on annuler le
mariage ne vous donne pas droit à une
pension alimentaire s'est donc trouvé
que ça n'était pas le but premier au
jour d'aujourd'hui il est bien évident
que comme n'importe quelle femme qui a
été qu'ils divorcent
je demande une pension alimentaire mais
effectivement il ya quelque chose de
très spécial
je demande une pension alimentaire
élevée qui est de l'ordre de 39 euros
par mois avec un mari qui annonce
environ 3000 francs de salaire par mois
j'espère avec cette demande que le
tribunal sera suffisamment dans
l'interrogation pour se dire il faut
faire une enquête sur les revenus de
monsieur lavandeira c'est tout ce que
j'espère en demandant aux jours d'un
ancien alimentaire c'est que le tribunal
enquête sur les revenus monsieur
l'amendé rats et je tiens à dire au
tribunal dès aujourd'hui que j'ai de
quoi l'informer voilà alors ce qu'il
faut dire effectivement c'est qu'à
l'automne dernier quand diego de l'avant
des rats se brouille avec son ami
antoine sous leurs fruits pas du tout
ils se bouffent pas du tout c'est son
père et ne serait de l'avant des rats
qui disent vous le foot est dehors
immédiatement c'est tout à fait
différent voulu recueillir
évidemment il est en chaussettes sur le
palier qui serait que je fasse je l' ai
connu tout petit vous lui dites à ce
moment là je dis rien du tout vous lui
dites pas la vérité sur les affaires de
son père et deux de glisse
il sent il sans doute cela dit moi je
suis sur un dossier de divorce qui est
en même temps effectivement une affaire
d'états et non pas une affaire de
pension alimentaire comme on a bien
voulu le dire et je lui ai je lui montre
mes dossiers parce qu'il est beaucoup
plus qu'avec moi dans l'ordinateur moi
je suis vraiment une panique totale donc
lui commence à naviguer et d'un coup il
a la révélation absolue qu'il y a comme
je le pense moi même effectivement un
une
comment une organisation à pionsat une
organise
sion qui lie à une organisation
criminelle qui en ce moment a à peu près
à sa disposition deux cent cinquante
fois le budget de la france
j'estime aujourd'hui malheureusement sg
pas eu envie que ça me tombe sur la tête
et ça m'amuse pas et c'est pas mes
oignons et c'est pas mes affaires je
suis dans une autre vie une artiste et
je n'ai envie de m'occuper que de ça
mais il n'empêche qu'aujourd'hui je me
lève pour dire faites attention vous
êtes aujourd'hui dans un extrême danger
alors évidemment depuis huit ans que
m'ont dit que je suis une folle une
droguée en fait c'est comme katherine
ainsi et effectivement ça a été très
difficile
aujourd'hui j'ai la chance merci didier
sous l'ère j'ai la chance de pouvoir
faire entendre ce que j'ai à dire c'est
pas pour moi encore une fois que je lui
ai dit c'est vraiment c'est pour vous on
va justement maintenant voir un petit
peu tout ce qui vous est reproché
on vous reproche de fréquenter antoine
soler et vous un personnage un peu
étrange un peu ambigu qui s'appelle
christian cotten qui s'est joint à vous
lui dit qu'il est psychosociologue
on le dit proche du mouvement sectaire
on le dit proche de l'extrême droite et
didier schuller d'ailleurs parle de
sectes fasciste européenne en ce qui le
concerne
qui est cette question que tu n es
comment avez vous été en contact avec
lui
antoine lui qui était toujours sur
l'ordinateur était en train de naviguer
comme on dit sur internet ce que je ne
vais pas faire et trouve un monsieur qui
a l'air de s'occuper très fort de
l'organisation du temps de ce
l'archevêque rappelle l'organisation
peut-être que l'ordre du temps où il se
trouve que malheureusement je suis en
mesure de donner des informations
puisque j'ai moi même et c'est mon mari
a essayé
de m'entraîner dans cette sicav d'accord
donc j'avais deux ou trois détails et je
me suis dit que dans le fond ce pauvre
monsieur k l'air de chercher des choses
j'ai convoqué monsieur cotten chez moi à
paris
je lui donnais les informations qui
étaient à ma disposition puisque c'est
mon témoignage et que je peux le prouver
je lui donnais sa merci au revoir
j'ai dit antoine quand nous sommes
rendrait tout l'été à genève on arrête
là c'est pas la peine d'essayer avec les
français nous avions déjà envoyé un
dossier à la 6ième webbys a l'air fou ce
que j'ai dit ah ouais ça a l'air
vraiment fonte avait alors on veut soit
vous faire taire effectivement soit vous
faire passer pour ça qu'avec ce que je
raconte mais sincèrement me raconterait
une histoire comme ça mais je suis la
première à dire maintenant la fille l
epic est allé à temps la vieille
chanteuse comme on dit dans ces pas quoi
elle et elle est malade elle est en
train dragon sauf que quand même quoi
qu'il en soit j'ai une masse de dossiers
qui ne sont pas écrits par mois c'est
bien évident j'ai une masse aujourd'hui
en l'espace de trois jours une seconde a
lancé remerciant m je voudrais faire
parvenir
s'il reste des juges en france du monde
me dit que vichnievsky est en train de
donner sa démission
on me dit qu eva joly donne sa démission
on a vu que monsieur halphen a donné sa
démission mais dites moi à qui on va
parler nous à moi à l'intéressé
alors antoine sous leur dit lui aussi
qu'il a reçu beaucoup de menaces genre
de coup de fil du genre fallait faire
attention de pas traverser oui en dehors
des clous 1 et on voit que c'est
dangereux parce que lui a dit ça il son
père didier schuller a déclaré si je me
suicide faudra pas y croire le déclarer
ça avant de partir de ça dommage on voit
bien quand même qu'on est dans un
problème mafieuse douceur présidence
n'ont pour l'instant lui il est dans un
problème politique mais il est évident
que ce qui s'est passé ou est repérée au
rpr à ce moment là je n'en sais rien
c'est pas mon problème je ne connais pas
didier soulet et j'en ai rien à secouer
s'il donne chirac ou pasqua a su sans
problème alors antoine schuller dit
antoine schuller dit que son père va
parler du financement du rpr mais qu'en
fait il parlera jamais des réseaux
supérieur qui contrôle tout ça alors
vous vous en parlait pas beaucoup mais
vous commencez à citer des noms vous
citer le nom de l'avant des rares là on
vient d'en parler vous citer le nom de
gobi et le nom de mimran comment vous
des français nous est alors ce pas des
français bien sûr qu'ils sont des
français on en rajoute et 2 to buy way
to buy ce jeu les prochains jours j non
ça c'est russe d'accord et morishita ces
japonais d'accord je tiens à dire aussi
que bienheureusement et d'une manière
que je n'attendais pas du tout depuis
deux jours à genève
j'ai vu au moins quatre hommes
d'affaires extrêmement sérieux
extrêmement important qui m'ont amené
environ 25 kg dossier je ne suis pas
seule il y as derrière moi et autour de
moi en ce moment des gens qui
spontanément vous venir dire ceux de
quoi ils ont été les témoins explique l
affaire elf explique l affaire de
l'hôtesse la base mais c'est exclu et
c'est hallucinant l'histoire c'est fou
c'est fou mais moi j'ai fait en fait au
travers de ça on a toute une mais andres
de choses autour en famille bien sûr
c'est beau mais cela dit je prends un
risque énorme en venant ici en venant à
dire tout ça c'est que ça ne m'amuse pas
j'ai rien à vendre
j'ai rien à le déshonneur il y en avait
je monte au créneau et je le ferai
incessamment ils ont vraiment fait
n'importe quoi avec mes enfants et ça je
le supporte pas c'est la raison de base
c'est la raison de base
c'est la raison de base tous tous les
cinq noms 1,4 dire que diego a été du
goût de la bagarre a été malade en fait
il a eu un cancer du poumon d'h2 cancer
voilà voilà un enfant qu'on soigne 27
ans
voilà un enfant qu'on soigne en lui
faisant des piqûres d'hormones mâles et
auquel on donne une somme de 400 mille
francs par mois pour avoir accès à
toutes les drogues ou dont il a envie
quand on l'envoie dans un centre ici à
paris il tombe sur un sur un psychiatre
qui lui dit tu en fais pas beaucoup je
suis franc maçon tu peux tu me dire il
sait très bien qu'il est dans les mains
de son père comment voulez vous que cet
enfant puisse venir à la surface puisse
exprimer ce qu'il a à dire
puis sortir de la drogue et du désarroi
dans lequel il est il n'a pas le droit
de me parler mais alors que vous avez
levé je les ai élevés il n'a pas le
droit depuis 94 il n'a pas le droit de
me parler quand il me parle il ya la
révolution et didier soulet remontre à
paris vous le croyez ça et j'ai moi mon
problème c'est que c'est louable j'ai du
mal à avoir de la peine pour pour ce
tome la cua parce que parce que je
connais à azouz il n'habite pas loin de
la peine parce qu'il à 400000 belle
parodie moi non plus c'est pas ça qui me
fait pleurer
on est bien d'accord cela dit son
problème reste le même
est-ce qu'on se rappelle quand même
qu'il y a que 15 % de la pollution la
population mondiale qu'un toit déjà
c'est exactement pour cela que je me
bats si t'as pas compris que c'est pour
cela que je me parle en fait on fait
cela pour faire péter cette saloperie de
2,2 mafia de merde sur la conjoncture
j'ai un problème un peu mais je peux
comprendre mais c'est pour eux que je me
bats je veux pas qu'on ait la révolution
je veux simplement avertir les gens leur
dire vous voyez bien qu'il se passe des
choses bizarres
il ya des gens - chaussée et ça ça n'a
rien oublié
c'est repoussé et puis l'hôte et s on en
parle plus on des gens qui se suicident
avec notre balles dans le corps mais on
nous prend pour des cons mais le v vous
nom d'un chien levé vous et les venait
dire mais arrêtez de nous prendre pour
des cons c'est pas vrai il se passe
quelque chose
j'ai pas envie d'être là ça me fait
chier mais je suis obligé de le faire
tu comprends mieux
[Applaudissements]
j'te rassure un truc que si personnel
bordel de merde c'était marc et la foire
est quand même
ouais voilà non parce qu'il ya quand
même un truc on entend qu'on entend moi
qui maillent qui m'a quand même marqué
puis je pense qu'à marquer tous les
français ses juges qui démissionnent est
actée n'est pas parce que les dégâts
soient arabes ou quoi un sens oui au
fait que je vais voir les juges ils sont
pas bons
[Applaudissements]
des chants et chansons qui ont marqué
notre vie
brighton parce que marie laforêt s'est
pas seulement la poule aux oeufs d'or
c'est pas seulement 50 films c'est pas
seulement les livres le théâtre c'était
aussi 35 millions d'albums vendus encore
mieux c'est lié à l'or et à toutes les
maisons de disques oui je balance bien
mais sur les 35 millions vous avez de
très peu près parce que toutes ces
compila qui sortent en ce moment qu'on
voit là le jour sur la fnac il y avait
cette compil fallu six autres contes et
marionnettes de ils ont fait cette
compilation 2010 en deux en proie à ses
démons des barons non voici c'est peu
c'est pas vrai j'ai reçu 9000 euros
amitié à lederman sa vie je n'ai pas
parlé d hermann [ __ ] alors je vais te
dire ce que je pense des leurs
tous ces succès vous n'avez pas chanter
sur scène depuis 30 ans et + 1972
exactement depuis 33 ans 33 ans l'âge du
christ tu te rends compte l'âge du
christ que j'ai pas chanter et vous
allez leur chanter sur scène du 12 au 17
septembre théâtre des bouffes parisiens
ouais depuis un mois que je suis
évidemment obligé de faire le top 6 des
chansons je suis enthousiasmé je suis
enchanté je suis ravi c'est ravissant
c'est charmant c'est gai c'est tonique
je suis enchanté de faire ça c'est enfin
bien peu non parce que tu sais pas c'est
que derrière cette opération il ya une
logistique impressionnante un requin du
show biz qui est en train de devenir le
parent les scènes parisiennes un tycoon
où un violent
ouais je dois dire que de ce côté là il
faut quand même je crois que gérard
louvin à côté c'est un petit rappeler
que didier violent également me l'a
confirmé tout à l'heure dans les loges
didier tu es chaud c'est pas moi qui
produit quelque chose tenerife la
sécheresse que j'aie bz amer
c'est à baiser la mer jeu suivant mais
d'abord pourquoi ta maman qui te regarde
c'est un coup de bol un moment bien
regarde bien il ya un producteur
absolument mais c'est un requin petits
plats africains
quand on se méfie pas parce que haut dé
plus sympa oui il a l'air comme ça pas
te la grippe mi novembre
je ne dirais pas de nature à m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le mât côté de qui j'ai en commun est un
petit garçon le nouveau requins du show
biz le producteur de marie laforêt c'est
laurent ruquier
voilà pour ceux en tout cas pour ce
spectacle mais c'est toi qui va conduire
marie laforêt oui exactement c'est moi
qui paye parce que j'avais envie de la
voir chanter
est ce que tu veux avoir assez et c'est
appris comment cet amour de marie
laforêt 2 fait attention à ce que je dis
depuis toujours
voilà c'est très bien ça depuis toujours
l'excellence je peux rien moi je ne
connaissais que les grands succès ce que
vous avez passé tout à l'heure et et que
tout le public connaît mais après grâce
aux fameuses compile même si elle n'a
rien touché dessus c'est compile auront
eu au moins un mérite c'est que j'ai
découvert des tas de chansons que
j'ignorais et qui sont toutes plus
belles les unes que les autres ce qui
est plus de 300 chansons sur scène il
faut dire que marie va chanter ses
grands succès ça fait plaisir
la majorité du public mais elle va aussi
chanter les chansons que on va dire ses
femmes ses aficionados ceux qui
connaissent tout son père répertoire les
chansons sud américaine les chansons
moins connues mais qui sont toutes aussi
belles et plus belle même parfois que
les grands succès tu te souviens des la
télé tu l'a découvert à la télé je me
sens mal c'est évidemment on va faire
une interview au matin je suis pas
chanter
[Musique]
si vous me répondez chanter quand vous
avez chanté la chanson est pas chanter
quand vous n'avez pas chanter on va voir
à marée haute à marée basse oui non non
chanté c'était quoi
à marée haute non je tendrais pompe
chanter non sur le brent coté ou pas
chanter sur scène chantera pas si cette
menace alors on y va
à marée haute à marée basse puissante et
aime moins jusqu'à demain sachant
chanter on connaît pas chanter chanter
chanter est moins 30 secondes de plus ça
changera ah non c'est aussi un test pour
voir si tu as tout cas tête alzheimer
après toi qui sais oui chantait jean
pascal il aussi que le barbecue n'ont
pas changé il chantait n'a pas chanté
barbecue bah oui en anglais à leur
arrivée du baseball magazine
ouais sainté c'est julia julie et julia
c'est jean-michel non c'est la chanter
je ne sais pas grand mais c'est sympa
c'est oui je les sentais dans une toile
que des amorces il estimé elle s'en
souvient à l'époque c'est pas grand mais
je regrettais en plus c'est tout moi
donc ça pas de gentils choukaj ou genou
époux époux sûrement c'est moi mais où
est donc ornicar non paulo elle pense et
clark hésiter bravo madame dhalla prime
guitare chanter comme en gilet en laine
non bon alors j'espère que c'est moi qui
fais les questions tellement compteur et
liverpool
oh oui roubles et mulhouse mais on en
plus le générique du para oui mulhouse
blues un prix non saint tropez blues ça
t'en fais siffler aussi phumaphi oui
suce ma fille très jolie très jolies
tenues dauphin le cachalot tous les
dauphins chanteuse santé chanter symbole
en santé bien sûr bien sûr
ah oui oui tout à fait oui oui oui
labiale ont tué des en plus tu pues très
marrante très triste et très bien son
nom vient rien viens viens viens viens
vers chantait si bien sûr la montagne
chanter malheureusement oui oui je viens
oui je viens non non non non wouah
warszawa oui 13h06 voir sa voix et
mourir ouais non non c'est moi d'amour
comme à une autre ouais bien leur
répertoire chanté d'abord sur moi
l'amour comme à 16 ans et je ne
connaissais pas fais moi l'amour comme à
une autre que j'ai entendu pour la
première fois il ya quinze ans j'ai bien
alors je suis folle de vous eh oui si
folle que vous chantez santé je suis
folle tout court oui c'est surtout la
façon d'isoler guitare une rente ai
chanté si et même si tu la chanteuse amy
guitare c'est michel accorder aux
patients qui plaît
j'ai certaines zones il n'y a ni guitare
les deux militaires blessés en août
tu t'y connais à mort c'est incroyable
on a une ou deux que je connaissais la
tour de babel
bah oui ça oui alors le chien de bébel
j'aime pas chanter ça au feu de bois
ça c'est un piège de la pizza au feu de
bois c'est passante et non c'est l'amour
au feu de bois
là oui c'est vrai ah oui là fromage
quatre saisons lève-toi et chante avec
moi oui oui si santé lève toi et marche
non pire n'est pas chanter c'est bien il
a neigé sur yesterday
ouais il a pissé sur images je regrette
de l'avoir fait mais ça va
[Musique]